[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv
soixante dix huit pour un nouveau numéro
du 7 8 sociétés votre rendez vous
hebdomadaire où on discute et on échange
sur des sujets d'actualité alors ce soir
on parlera de zoothérapie le ronron du
chat le chien le câlin du chien des
instants apaisant vous avez sans doute
déjà entendu des propriétaires d'animaux
le dire depuis le xviiie siècle et
qualité de médiation de l'animal sont
connus mais pourquoi des professionnels
ont recours à nos amis à poils et à pâte
et non pas avec nos invités
esther les personnes martinez bonsoir
vous êtes psychologue pour l'association
française de thérapie assistée par
l'animal vous intervenez dans les
hauts-de-seine et les yvelines mariri
veness bonsoir vous êtes fondatrice de
l'esprit des qui est un organisme de
formation spécialisé en management grâce
au cheval
alors je dise aux thérapies non pas
surtout de médiation animale et on pense
aussi aux soins médicaux sociaux
externes les ersonne martinez vous êtes
donc psychologue
comment est-ce que vous en êtes venu à
travailler que les animaux alors moi du
coup effectivement je suis à petit col
up initiale de formation
j'ai toujours été intéressé par les
médiations thérapeutique de manière
générale au début c'était pas forcément
avec l'animal j'ai eu l'occasion de
pratiquer au tour d'autres médiateurs
mais je me suis rendu compte à un moment
donné que ce type de format permettait
un véritable travail psychique avec
certains patients qui n'avaient pas
forcément accroché à un cadre de
psychothérapie qu'on peut appeler
classique voilà en parallèle j'ai
toujours été bien sûr passionné par par
le lien homme-animal les animaux
également toujours fait partie de ma vie
donc je suis
naturellement sensibiliser à l'alliance
entre le loin le soin psychologique qui
l'animal médiateur qui peut constituer
pour moi un véritable partenaire
thérapeutique alors ses plumes qui vous
accompagne dans vos séances et un golden
retriever tout jeune elle a un peu plus
d'un an qu'est ce qu'elle vous apporte
et pourquoi le chien dans vos séances
n'a pas écouté le chien ça aurait pu
être un autre animal je m'intéresse
aussi à l'équithérapie le chien en
l'occurrence parce que je me suis fait
écouter par l'association française de
thérapie assistée par l'animal qui
travaillent qui ne travaille qu'avec le
chien plus est ce qu'elle va apporter
dans les séances
c'est tout simplement sa présence c'est
un facilitateur social en facilitateur
de rencontres et des changes
donc elle peut apporter bien évidemment
des choses différentes en fonction de
chaque patient en fonction de la
problématique on va sur laquelle on va
vouloir travailler
voilà pour le moment c'est le chien il
faut dire quand même que c'est un animal
proche de l'homme et que en institution
avec le chien ça marche vraiment très
bien avec certains patients marie
divionnais ce vous avez fait le choix de
travailler que des compagnons un peu
plus imposant puisque ce sont des
chevaux
qu'est ce qui vous a attiré avec ce
compagnon l'a bel et bien merci madame
awa le cheval est un excellent
facilitateur des apprentissages donc au
même titre que les chiens ou les chats
de compagnie néanmoins davantage qu'il a
lorsqu'on fait les formations en
management c'est qu'il a une très grande
finesse dans ses interactions sociales
puisque c'est un animal de troupeaux qui
une croix dans la nature donc il ya
développé une grande capacité à
identifier et à comprendre les signaux
et le langage corporel et lorsqu'on
travaille avec le cheval dans le milieu
de l'entreprise pour pour 3 pour
favoriser la cité de l'énergie pour
prendre confiance en soi dans un groupe
dans son institution le cheval va va
être un décodeur de vos comportements et
mettre l'accent là où ça peut être
difficile ou bien là où vous avez des
atouts qui va falloir travailler mettre
en valeur
et puis c'est également le parement
jauge low cost également 1,1 et merck
est imposant et lors des ateliers les
participants sont dans une zone un petit
peu d'inconfort c'est ça va l'aider tous
et les amener à les chercher au fond
d'eux mêmes des solutions à à une
situation qui ne veut qu'ils ne
connaissent pas qui ne peuvent pas
maîtriser ni par la force qui parle le
langage donc seul aspect dimension du
cheval l'a77 intérêt de faire des
situations d'apprentissage en dans une
situation d'inconfort qui va énormément
facilité les les acquisitions de
nouveaux comportements
vous l'avez dit en quelques mots vous ne
travaillez pas dans le domaine médical
vos cheveux ne sont pas là pour des
patients vous avez choisi le domaine
managériale pourquoi qu'est-ce que chez
le cheval peut apporter
de ce côté là alors c'est justement dans
le milieu de l'entreprise on est
confronté à des valeurs différentes
comportement différent travail à des
personnes qui ne sont pas nos ennemis
on n'a pas forcément les mêmes les mêmes
codes et
le travail que nous faisons sont des
ateliers collectifs où le cheval va être
utilisé comme un moyen de partager ses
propres valeurs typiquement on a un
petit atelier qui consistent simplement
je dévoile un petit peu des choses sur
notre formation et qu'ensuite simplement
choisir un cheval et lorsqu'on souhaite
devenir du bateau qu'on peut voir on
explique on a choisi tel cheval on va
voir les personnes qu'ils ont que
j'allais choisir un cheval fort j'avais
un cheval veut dire assurant d'autre
cheval impressionnant plutôt dominante
et ce choix va être le guider par par
une valeur intrinsèque c'est parfois
inconsciente
c'est intéressant de voir ses collègues
sous un autre angle ou le drh qui devait
le solliciter pour une formation va être
extrêmement friands de ce type
d'expérience parce que les salariés les
équipes apprennent à se connaître
et lorsqu'on a une culture différente
également quelques cas dans mon
entreprise
par ailleurs c'est valorisant pour les
uns et pour les autres et ça lève
beaucoup d'incompréhension et diminue
fortement le risque de conflits
interpersonnels espèrent les personnes
martinez comment est-ce qu'on forme un
chien à faire de la médiation animale
j'imagine qu'on ne peut pas aller vers
toutes les races d'animaux
alors là effectivement alors pas dépend
parce que dans le paysage de la
médiation animale
il ya des intervenants qui interviennent
avec des chiens de toutes races ou à la
star on a choisi elle va pas revenir
avec les golden retriever alors comment
on forme le chien
le chien n'est pas nécessairement formé
pour être un média thouars il est formé
pour être un chien de famille avant tout
c'est le contact qu'on souhaite guillais
avec les patients et avec les structures
on évite de trop fort mais les chiens
parce qu'on ne veut pas de chien robot
c'est tellement important de laisser la
place à l'imprévu et à la spontanéité
parce que ça amène également de la
matière au niveau clinique
voilà après concernant le golden
retriever à à l'époque avant 2013 l'aft
a récupéré des chiens les foires des
chiens guides d'aveuglés réformé depuis
2013 il ya un pôle famille d'accueil qui
permet à l'association d'acheter des
chiots dès leur plus jeune âge est et de
l'est de les mettre en famille pendant
pendant un an pour qu'ils soient éduqués
dans une famille tout simplement qu'il
est utilisé une vie de famille et qu'on
puisse les connaître le golden retriever
parce que sa couleur est une couleur
claire qui en général est plus douce
on va éviter par exemple les chiens
noirs le poil est plus agréable au
toucher pas trop gras il ya une
sensation plus et génique et bien sûr
par rapport à son caractère parce que
c'est un chien sociable proche de
l'homme affectif est plutôt obéissant
bien qu'il garde toujours ses parts de
comme je les dis de spontanéité qui
reste très importante à nos yeux pour
garantir une relation qu'ils soient
humaines et non proto commises et avec
avec le patient
c'est une question pour toutes les deux
on voit ce que ces animaux nous apporte
mais est ce que il a précicé temps des
changes alors marie jimenez avec vos
clients par hasard par exemple par nous
c est ce que les animaux apprécient
cesser cette expérience oui alors nous
j'ai expliqué qu' on est très engagé
le bien-être et qu'un structures
labellisées l'environnement et du
bien-être animal
donc effectivement roubaix à ce que les
chevaux ne soient pas stressés par les
ateliers c'est pas neutre pour un cheval
un atelier parce que nous on venus tels
des humains qui n'ont pas les codes
habituels
on peut envoyer avec les chevaux nos
chevaux sont très habitués extrêmement
respectueux pour des questions de
sécurité même si j'adhère complètement à
ce que dit esther concernant la
spontanéité dont on a besoin à part de
ces animaux là c'est limite avec le
cheval c'est que c'est un gros et du mal
qui peut être dangereux
donc il ya un certain nombre de codes
lorsque le cheval donc je reviens sur
sur votre question lorsqu'on est
confronté à différents trajets air
autour de lui l'en cet atelier j'ai
certains chevaux pour qui ça peut être
compliqué de savoir quelle est la
réponse à apporter
parce qu'il a énormément fini autour de
lui alors lorsque ça se passe comme ça
généralement mais c'est un petit peu de
temps et puis on va reprendre le cheval
pour lui demander d exercice qui connaît
pour leur mac lui dans sa zone de
confort ce n est pas de la queue de
cheval un prix moindre inconfort autant
les instruments c'est ce qu'ils viennent
chercher autant les chevaux ne l'ont pas
le land a demandé me mais d'une manière
générale
mes chevaux chaque atelier à la fin des
ateliers il reste autour des autour des
participants donc je vous dis qu il ne
trouve pas ça trop désagréable même
question pour vous et stars et les
ersonne martinez à ce que plume apprécié
ces temps d'échangés avec vos passions
bah écoutez je pense que oui en tout cas
on fait tout pour bien évidemment comme
l'a dit marie on aime aussi très engagé
dans le bien-être et le confort de
l'animal est une priorité absolue
pour nous les séances en tout cas pour
pour l'animal les séances sont plutôt
confortables en général parce qu'il
s'agit de prendre soin de l'animal donc
de bronze des données des groupes y est
de se détendre énormément de se coucher
sur une table de travail
y'a rien qui qui est au dessus des
capacités d'un chien de famille
classique finalement des petits ordres a
répété un peu de dressage donc oui plus
apprécié en général ces séances là je le
vois pas ce qu'il remonte sur la table
de travail à chaque fois et avait
manifesté là ça se verrait donc on fait
tout en tout cas pour que ce soit le
plus confortable et possiblement pour le
chien et et en nous pensons que salée
jusqu'à présent alors on parle du chat
et du chien depuis tout à l'heure ce
sont quand même les animaux les plus
connus dans l'azoté rapide mais certains
font appel à d'autres compagnons et je
vous propose qu'on aille à gaz rang et
l'eau et les eaux nancy nocquet a été
faire un reportage à l'ehpad relais
tendresse qui organise une chouette
thérapie pour ses 90 résidents au regard
des deux animateurs des personnes âgées
et des chouettes ce sont les ingrédients
nécessaires pour un rendez vous original
la chouette thérapie tous les mois les
pattes de gaz rend organise cette
activité pour ses résidents
c'est une activité qui est complètement
insolite puisque on n'a pas l'habitude
de voir des chouettes au des hiboux
régulièrement et
mais on se rend compte que des résidants
qui pourrait être un peu renfermé qui ne
discutent pas beaucoup et on voit leurs
visages qui s'illumine mise en place
depuis 2010 9 grâce au mécénat de
l'entreprise gecina immobilier dix
séances d'une heure environ sont
organisées par an à la manoeuvre le parc
animalier l'espace rambouillet qui
compte 150 rapaces le fait de porter des
rivales sauvage dans une résidence et de
faire voler cette fois joseph daul faire
porter sur le dos ça ça va en place des
émotions des souvenirs ça fait bouger
les résidents aussi parce qu'il faut se
lever
tendre le bras rappeler la chouette ça
les met en valeur lundi 12 avril une
vingtaine de résidents participer à
cette chouette thérapie un bon moyen
pour découvrir ou redécouvrir ces
animaux et en apprendre un peu plus sur
eux moi j'adore tous les animaux alors
je suis fait j'étais grand tante et j'ai
passé une bonne après un face à une
bonne journée agréable
pourquoi parce qu'on apprend des choses
toujours sa saisie mais on l'a on a peur
si vous voulez sang du christ en europe
c'est absolument génial
il ya deux personnes qui sont vraiment
très cultivé qui nous aura appris
beaucoup de choses
une conférence sur les rapaces est
également organisée avec l'espace
rambouillet d'ici deux semaines dans
l'établissement des activités plutôt
chouette donc que l'ehpad de gaz rang et
ses 90 résidents espère faire perdurer
longtemps espère que les personnes
martinez on a entendu la directrice de
l'établissement
dire que certains de ces résidences
ouvre au contact de ces chouettes que le
visage s'illumine c'est quelque chose
que vous voyez aussi chez vos patients
tout à fait tout à fait ce qui est
intéressant avec avec les séances autour
de la thérapie assistée par deux chiens
que quand on arrive en structure est con
on est con dit bonjour aux patients le
la séance fait toujours événement en
fait pour c'est toujours un événement
dont ils se souviennent au moins du
chien dans le cas où ce sont des
personnes âgées et que la mémoire est
atteinte
mais voilà c'est toujours un moment de
plaisir et ils se souviennent assez
souvent du plaisir qui a été déjà
procuré par par ce temps là donc le
chien permet de faire événement en fait
pour eux et juste ça c'est déjà c'est
déjà très très bien pour pour des
personnes atteintes par des troubles
cognitifs m'arrive une rive hoeness sur
votre site internet vous indiquer que le
cheval révèlent des comportements
discret des individus qu'est ce que vous
entendez par discret des choses qu'on
n'ose pas de montrer en entreprise
pourrait tout à fait c'est effectivement
des mimiques des expressions parfois une
orientation du corps qui ne va pas
nécessairement avec ce que l'on dit le
cheval ne parle pas de langage verbal
néanmoins ils parlent un langage
corporel le comprend et donc c'est en
cela qu'ils révèlent des comportements
de ministres est ce que ce que j'appelle
des comportements distraire et qui sont
naturellement décotée par nous les êtres
humains on n'y met pas nécessairement
des monts néanmoins il peut arriver
pendant qu'on ait un certain malaise
quand en discuter avec quelqu'un qui
nous donne une phrase ou l'infirmation
et puis un montant qui était un peu en
retrait les épaules les épaules
légèrement rentrée les bras qu'ils ont
peut-être donc ce genre de deux courbes
de langage non verbal est assez feu
conscientiser par l'être humain
néanmoins une influence notre relation à
l'autre
est-ce que qu'est ce que les entreprises
viennent chercher quand elle vous
contacte à esprit d qui sait pour une
cohésion de groupe c pour certains
salariés peut-être trop timide comme
vous me le disait peut-être pour
envisager d'aider des promotions et de
voir qui pourrait prendre le leadership
dans une équipe quelle qu'elle vienne
chercher
effectivement c'est un peu tout ça
remuait
à première demande en général c'est les
conflits entre équipes on a affaire des
conflits au sein d'une bonne équipe on
est une entreprise qui a un gros projet
qui a besoin que toute l'équipe soit
soit moteur engagé à faire des heures
sup et il ya parfois des conflits
interpersonnels buren qui viennent
entraver la performance des uns et des
autres est finie la performance de
l'entreprise
donc ça c'est un premier c'est vraiment
la première demande et donc on va te
liées qui sont spécifiques à ce type de
problématique
on a également noté la deuxième demande
aussi importantes c'est pour des cadres
mais on prend pas que les calmer en
général on comprend on prend toute
l'équipe sur la thématique du leader
effectivement comme vous disiez il y a
il ya des choses qui ont dit qu'ils ne
s'apprennent pas merveilleux et et
aurait été où on peut les apprendre
encore faut-il avoir le bon miroir bonne
interprète et le travail sont l'énergie
lorsqu'on doit emmener toute une équipe
sur un projet ça c'est une vraie demande
lorsque et 1 c'est particulièrement vrai
en ce moment avec donc en pleine crise
perry taire parce que les gens voient
travailler de manière différente et il
faut savoir vivoter assez rapidement
s'adapter son business model et parfois
donc la façon dont les gens travaillent
et ça que ça implique énormément de
changements des gens qui sont pas
toujours prêts à changer ou qui ont des
craintes et hélas le lait celui des
kills à la formation nous proposons
aller avec ce qui est assez efficace à
la pandera dotarem intéressant et
c'était les airs sonne martinez est ce
que la thérapie assistée par le chien
que vous pratiquez s'adapte à tous les
publics où il y a des profils qui seront
jamais réceptif à l'animal par rapport à
l'association afa on lui dit absolument
pas
le type de population visée la seule
limite c'est celle de l'intervenant qui
est donc tous les intervenants de
l'équipe sont des personnes issues du
milieu paramédical de profs de
professions paramédicales
donc la seule limite finalement ça va
être les ficelles des compétences de
chaque intervenant un psychomotricien ne
va peut-être pas aller vers la même
population qu'un psychologue
voilà mais sinon on a à coeur et ça fait
partie de nos valeurs que nos
interventions plus en tout cas que les
bienfaits de la thérapie assistée par
l'animal puisse toucher le maximum de
personnes
prescription médicale est ce qu'un
médecin psychiatre en ville en libéral
peut prescrire une thérapie par l'animal
à suivre le oui et non c'est simplement
une orientation un confrère ou une
console psychiatre qui soit prêt tester
un autre type de prise en charge avec
avec un patient peut tout à fait en
voyant libéral à un psychologue qui
pratiquent la médiation animale un ou
plusieurs patients alors pour chaque
émission nous posons une question à nos
téléspectateurs dès cette semaine nous
souhaitions savoir s'il fallait
développer et l'az et la zoothérapie la
médiation par avec l'animal et la grande
majorité de nos téléspectateurs 1
répondent oui est ce que c'est une
volonté que vous comprenez mari venaient
la volonté de la part des de nos
téléspectateurs
oui alors je pense que c'est ça c'est ça
témoigne et particulièrement du suspense
dans le contexte dans lequel une somme
d'animal c'est un peu ce qui nourrit à
la terre et je crois qu'on a aujourd'hui
tous énormément souffert déconfinement
de l'incertitude de la peur de la perte
de proches parfois et et je pense qu'on
a un retour aux sources vers des choses
qui nous qui me rappelle que nous sommes
bien vivants elle nous faisons partie
non
dans l'écosystème une certaine cohérence
donc je suis pas très surprise par par
là l'intention la réponse de l'eau
évitables esther l'exercice martinez
vous le comprenez aussi que les gens se
disent qu il faut développer la
médiation par l'animal on parlait de
l'aco vitesse qu'en plus seulement que
de contact ce manque de sociabilisation
qu'on peut avoir depuis un an a renforcé
l'intérêt de l'animal c'est bien
possible où il effectivement moi je suis
complètement d'accord avec ce que disait
madame rivenet les les personnes de plus
en plus tendance à se tourner vers des
choses finalement de plus en plus simple
après c'est vrai que il faut quand même
préciser que le médiateur animal qu'ils
soient cadres un ou une quinte et
puissant mais mais pas miraculeux et qu'
il ne va finalement concerner qu'un
certain nombre de patients qui témoigna
déjà d'en enterrer dans d'entrée et qui
en témoigner avant donc aussi avant que
vides pour le chien pour denimal voilà
ça vient s'inscrire dans une prise en
charge globale du patient en institution
ou en libéral
mais c'est vrai que il en va quand même
de préciser qu'il y à des patients pour
qui c'est une autre médiation
thérapeutique qui est qui est plus
adapté ou un autre type de prise en
charge et puis pour ça on a le choix il
ya énormément de pratiques dans ce
domaine là mais voilà c'est le que ce
soir de chien ou le cheval ou la
chouette ça reste un médiateur qui n'est
pas universelle et qui conviendra à
certaines personnes mais pas à tout le
monde vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure un
peu avant dans l'émission que vous êtes
très attentive au bien-être de l'animal
est ce que vos méthodes sont bien
acceptés par les proches des patients ou
des salariés collaborateurs d'une
entreprise
est-ce qu'il ya aussi des critiques
d'associations d'organisations de
protection animale est ce que vous avez
rencontrés çà alors allez vous n'arrivez
né en premier je donnerai la parole
esther des personnes alors je ne vais
pas j'ai pas rencontré de critiques à ce
niveau là
un protocole extrêmement strict sur sur
la vie des chevaux ou qui vivent en
extérieur ils ne sont pas faits réglisse
ont travaillé régulièrement vous pas
risquer aux pattes donc donc non on n'a
pas non non j'ai pas du tout été
confronté à ça bien au contraire et
c'est aussi une à une bonne occasion de
parler aux gens qui n'ont pas accès à
certains contacts avec le cheval seconde
à la thérapie l'équipe hôte chine peut
être pratiqué ces thérapies c'est cette
une
c'est une formation manager qui peut
être pratiqué même si on n'a pas
d'affinités particulières avec le cheval
et qui même marche encore vous lorsqu'on
n'a pas d'affinités particulières avec
le cheval c'est ce sont des jeunes qui
en mêlant du coup c'est aussi l'occasion
lorsqu'on à nos participants de revenir
un petit peu sur sur les fondamentaux du
bien-être animal et du mode de vie
notamment des choix en ce moment c'est
un débat et je crois également donc sur
sur les animaux de compagnie sion se
testait rouages du film que la mienne
sur ces sujets la parole vous donne des
récitals les airs sont absolument pas
une analyse fine pour le moment me
concernant je n'ai pas du tout eu vent
de critiques ou de de controverse par
rapport à cette pratique
c'est vrai que mon chien sont une vie de
famille ne sont absolument pas en revue
d'une vivre comme un autre comme le
chien du monsieur et madame tout le
monde
la seule particularité c'est qu'ils nous
suivent
autant dans notre vie professionnelle
que dans notre vie personnelle
voilà vis-à-vis de l'entourage
je rencontre très peu de familles
assurant je suis en tant que psychologue
il ya toujours les tic du secret
professionnel bien évidemment
l'accompagnement thérapeutique
je propose à chaque patient lui a par
contre totalement doit d'y être
privilégiez donc le contact avec les
familles et à ses moindres en tout cas
de mon côté c'est plus du côté de la
structure que ça va se faire dans ce
contexte c'est sur ces mots comparé
terminer ce set une société maintenant
terminé merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau temps des changes
d'ici là prenez soin de vous
[Musique]